è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo vi dò io sono bari j
ed oggi siamo qui in un nuovo blog raga
incredibile faccio un blog
impossibile che tra il mondo tra poco
sicuro no perché non faccio un blog da
forniti con l'ultima volta che ho fatto
un blog sala tipo mi pare o due o tre
mesi fa c'è una roba legge va beh
comunque non faccio blog da anni secoli
millenni va beh diciamo che i blog sono
importanti diciamo secondo me perché
secondo me il rapporto con i propri
iscritti dovrebbe essere diciamo più
consolidato tra virgolette con i blog
quindi dovrei aumentare il numero di
blog che faccio e a tal proposito ho
avuto un'idea ultimamente che mi è
piaciuta parecchio adesso poi sapere che
cosa ne pensate voi ho intenzione di
fare circa un blog alla settimana se non
proprio ogni settimana ogni due non lo
so adesso vedo e ho intenzione di
strutturare ogni blog in una certa
maniera allora la struttura dei blog che
ho intenzione di fare nella sono scritta
sto parlando in basso perché non sono
scritta praticamente voglio iniziare
ogni blogger adesso in avanti con una
fan art che sarebbe la parte più bella
della settimana che sceglierò appunto di
settimana in settimana e per fare un
esempio direi di iniziare da questo blog
la fa nato della settimana e questa
fatta da beatrice a mio parere veramente
fantastica quindi i meriti di vincere la
parata della settimana per questa
settimana di prova e niente non esempio
di quote che intenzione di fare e questo
è uno dei punti diciamo il secondo punto
sto con sempre guardando foglio è quello
delle domande perché ho intenzione di
rispondere alle vostre domande ogni blog
che saranno non so quante due o tre
penso comunque va beh per fare un
esempio risponde alle domande che mi
fate frequentemente con i j se un
maschio e una femmina sono un maschio
sto leggendo la fim ed ho scritto anche
nel risposto mi sono anzi ne siano ma ti
faccio i luoghi così ciao a tutti io
sono fa vj e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video e adesso sfuma beh per farvi
capire che non vince ogni 4 secondi sono
le goave comunque sono maschio
ho i capelli
non ho soltanto una mano ma attenzione
ne ho due
queste sono le risposte del blog di oggi
benissimo allora gli altri punti era che
allora ad ogni blog
se riesco nello scorso blog che avevo
fatto secoli fa aveva aperto un
pacchetto che mi era arrivato per posta
dei fan ho intenzione di fare questa
cosa di aprire un parco che mi mandate
voi ad ogni blog però per farlo devo
fare un punto posta praticamente perché
non intenzione di farli arrivare tutti a
casa mia se non devo scendere ogni 4
secondi a prendere il pacchetto quindi
ha intenzione di fare un punto posto non
sono che come si chiamano in fermoposta
forse non mi ricordo come si chiamano va
beh ovviamente è un indirizzo che non è
quello di casa mia ma un indirizzo di
posta nel quale potrete inviare dei
pacchi se volete io poi gli aprirono i
blog futuri ve lo farò sapere o su
facebook comunque nel prossimo blog e
l'indirizzo di posta al quale mandarmi i
pacchetti che poi io aprirò il pacco di
oggi celo celo ragazzi ce lo è per
questa volta aprirò questo pacchetto qui
anche se non so ancora il fermo posta va
beh direi di iniziare ad aprirlo perché
ce l'ho qui da stamattina è una roba in
norma ragazzi la prossima volta potete
anche inviarmi un canguro se volete
perché non so è più grosso di me sto
cazzo di pacco va beh direi di aprirlo
perché non so che cosa c'è dentro quindi
iniziamo cazzo mi sento maria de filippi
c'è posta per te o quasi non lo so però
che apriamo madonna mia voce ragazzi ci
siamo visto dimentica di dire che il
pacco mi è stato inviato da c'è scritto
il nome da qualche parte
dio mio santissimo mi sembra di guardare
è che a equa dietro perfetto martina
martina perfetto grazie mille martina da
villafranca grazie mille per aver
inviato stoffa
allora mi avete inviato delle mentos
fantastico ricevuto delle menti che
cazzo vedete inviato dall evento forse
falco la rito cattivo non awlaki l'alito
cattivo perché mi avete inviato ma che
ne so io non so se mangiarla perché ho
paura che la vetta labiata avvelenata ma
io non lo so per sicurezza
[Musica]
dopodiché mi avete inviato cos'è questo
un telecomando
grazie mille ma funziona sta roba non ho
sotterrato il proviamo un secondo che
fico se funziona grazie al telecomando
fa deejay tv sei unico
ma c'è anche compreso dpa ci sono anche
le pile grazie mille sul telecomando era
la cosa che mi serviva è stato
rimpiazzato quello vecchio mi stava bene
grazie del telecomando molto utile ho
ricevuto un'altra nutella ragazzi
guardateli sopra c'è non so perché è
sfocato ave dietro me che farei quello
lì è che mario e stitch adesso nuovo ci
sono due nutella adesso c'è anche la
terza ragazzi mi volete riempire lo
scaffale minutella ma cosa avete fatto
ciò che la mia foto bellissima grazie
mille
l'afa vitella la fa vita giustamente la
nuova marca da un hotel all'afa vitella
c'è anche la copertina della mia pagina
facebook fantastico mangiami sono buona
va bene io questo poi lo deciderò in
seguito poco alla paritella abbiamo un
cos'è sta cosa quindi un cartone o mio
dio
cos'è sta schifezza ciao favino molto
tempo ormai che ti seguono ripiego ma il
fatto di aver premuto quel maledetto
pasto iscriviti
grazie a delle mie giornate sono
diventate molto più allegre più epiche
veramente speciali in ogni tua piccola
cazzata grazie mille molto romantico o
quando diceva parolacce perché ti fanno
sembrare f laica basta dire che ti
seguiamo tuteliamo parato unica e sola
originalità ti vogliamo bene pochi j wow
fantastico grazie infinite
sono troppo sexy spot ragazzi wow
veramente epico grazie vera c'è anche
kate mario grazie veramente epico e
infine c'è questo che non so che cosa
sarà una bomba o mio dio guarda pack
cos'è per fa vj come cos'è noi che figo
mi avete poche stile una una piastrina
una piastrina da militare con scritto
zuma brutta stronza di una videocamera
paghi j 8 12 2012 condannato il canale
migliaio cover del mondo grazie infine
da questa veramente a c'è anche un'altra
cosa cosa è questo un fiocchetto più
questo è un fiocco che probabilmente è
stato preso dalle barbie e io per non lo
so e lo metto così fantastico non sono
sexy sono veramente figo
ok grazie mille poi la piastrina doppio
strina epica non posso metterla perché
ciò le coppie che sono quattro volte la
mia testa ma poi la metto quindi ragazzi
il pacchetto di oggi l'ho aperto vi dico
tanto lo farò sapere su facebook quando
aprirà al fermo apposta così potete
inviarmi quello che volete ne avrò da
aprire abbastanza ave comunque questa è
un'altra è sarebbe un altro punto del
blog va bene le nuove serie alla ragazzi
avevo detto sto facendo il logo e così
sono veramente fantastico per quanto
riguarda le serie nuova ragazzi abbiamo
iniziato che mario 3 che ho visto che è
piaciuto tantissimo almeno a voi
vabbè poi per quanto riguarda just dance
che non state chiedendo ormai anche
nella hall che la notte mi sogno mai che
mi chiedete poi fai just dance lo farò
just dance state tranquilli la prossima
settimana e poi ho un casino di progetti
ragazzi anche per i prossimi speciali
spero che vi piacciono tantissimo
intenzione di portare avanti il minifilm
this land che avevo iniziato secoli fa
minifilm proprio delle clip che secondo
me può venire fuori una bella cosa ben
più avanti lo farò di sicuro intanto
calcio il fiocchetto mi sta coprendo
abituale che è perfetto
ho intenzione di farlo quindi ragazzi
aspettatevelo più avanti e ho in mente
parecchi speciali a parte mio padre che
balla just dance poi più avanti vedrete
non visto spoilerare nulla invece per
quanto riguarda just dance vero e
proprio uscirà la prossima settimana
quindi state tranquilli
ok ragazzi dire che per oggi è tutto
devo dirvi soltanto un'ultima cosa
praticamente oggi e sabato i prossimi
tre giorni quindi domenica lunedì e
martedì
raga non ci saranno video perché non
sono a casa in questi tre giorni e non
ha avuto tempo di registrare ancora
nulla quindi ragazzi per questi tre
giorni di guardatevi le playlist vecchi
oppure qualche video vecchio che non
avete visto però non potrò far uscire
video perché non sono a casa quindi
ripartiremo da mercoledì sappiate che se
mercoledì non vedete vide perché sono
morti quindi per tre giorni non ci
saranno video purtroppo perché non ci
sono ma poi riprenderemo tranquillamente
state tranquilli quindi direi che per
oggi ho vinto tutto sto vagliate lo
posso anche gustare la scaletta velo
detta poi più avanti aggiungerò delle
cose per i nuovi blog che farò perché
questi erano soltanto dei punti diciamo
messi un po così per oggi sicuro farò
una cosa della settimana da fan art dei
fac dei pacchetti che riceverò di sicura
è la risposta ad alcune vostre domande
di sicuro anche quella poi vetroso
aggiungere dell'altro
fatemi sapere che cosa ne pensate io per
oggi la chiudo qui ragazzi debito è
piaciuto come al solito lasciate un
commento vi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook come in ogni video tratte nella
descrizione scena siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al prossimo
vitobello ragazzi